ammazza che allegria suo posto ok
ok
ed è lo stop sia giusto switch way
tranche lauro figlio non averlo cazzo
stockeau
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
questo è un mio amico che come potete
vedere c'è una bella pittura rossa in
faccia che spero sia un eritema o
qualcosa del genere che non sia sangue
vabbè comunque questo videogame e un
indie chiamato stalker
volevo salutare l'inizio ma siamo
partiti subito male perché non lo so
oddio cos'è cos'è era quello permesso
vai avanti tu cos'è questo odio e morto
è morto
sì mi prendo il fucile grazia
ok se abbiamo calmi non ci sto già
capendo più niente ho appena iniziato
sono trenta secondi di gioco allora
siamo partiti che c'era sto qui che mi
parlava in inglese ma non ho capito
niente mai guardare lo stalker ha detto
una roba del genere e poi niente
qualcuno è entrato nel muro e ucciso mio
amico perfetto
comunque questo è un indie chiamato
stoica add on in dior ora ovviamente è
trovato il download in descrizione se lo
volete scaricare se siete così pazzi da
scaricarlo e o che bello salve già per
caso mi dice dove è andato prima è uno
entrato nel muro
io vado avanti vado avanti a quache ci
sono le sue gambe qui a lì c'è anche non
c'è anche un piede se se lo vuole non
glielo porto per ora ci sono altre gambe
io vado comunque lì ci sono le gambe
faccia con comodo a ce ne sono altre qui
quindi ha l'imbarazzo della scelta
proprio le lascio a lei comunque è un
videogame che mi avete consigliato cos'è
questo cos'è oh mio dio io vado pazzo
ogni tanto si vede che batte
le sbatte le palpebre il personaggio
dove vado a sinistra adesso a sinistra
non ho idea di che videogame o rossi ama
è un qualcosa di non sense buongiorno è
andato di qua vero dato di qua si vede
raga questo muro e tipo quello di harry
potter del binario 9 e 3 quarti se ci
corre entri dentro perché provo facciata
me lo aspettavo ragazzi comunque andiamo
avanti che se questo cos'è non lo so non
mi interessa saperlo andiamo avanti
va bene l'ambiente è fantastico non ce
n'è anche una torcia o mio dio
salve mi dite chi vi ha messo qui sopra
ok ci sono anche per voi le gambe andata
indietro che avanzano comunque non ha
idea di che cosa debba fare
penso che quello sia lo stalker perché
il gioco si chiama stalker
immagino che cosa sia lo stalker questo
qua è rimasto impalato che bello
vabbè ottima posizione per dormire
comunque io volte dormo peggio
allora non ho idea di dove des bains
dare un'idea di cosa debba fare ok è
caduto la scatola mi son cagato addosso
per una scatola stai tranquillo favia
una scatola chi ha buttato una scatola
sono quei maledetti potevate beccare in
testa qualcuno disgraziati
ok barili di sangue fantastico
nell'audio non è che non sento così
niente comunque di sottofondo raga
quindi come audio siamo messi abbastanza
cos'è help me kiki devo aiutare di me
dammi informazioni una mail qualcosa
dicevo ad audio siamo messi abbastanza
bene perché non c'è audio quasi sento
ogni tanto al cuore che batte ma proprio
quel leggero quindi voi sentirete
soltanto me
dimenticavo che questo il primo commento
di che sentite con queste cuffie quindi
ditemi se si sente meglio degli altri
comunque allora vado avanti imperio
dovrebbe sentirsi meglio
o anche il dolby sorround se cuffie
quindi gli infarti dovrei prendermi di
meglio soltanto che non c'è audio quindi
niente da fare cos'è questo
vabbè alte ma anche soltanto una gamba
buongiorno a te manca proprio tutto
posso portarti con me perché sei molto
carino e mi dai tranquillità ok ok
successo qualcosa è successo qualcosa mi
sono scagliato addosso solo per l'audio
oddio all'improvviso pensavo che avesse
preso vita la faccia ma non è stato così
credo che starò manoleva tiriamo su non
so che lo serve ma tiriamo su benissimo
ok laga un casino sto gioco raga mai
fatto proprio così ok non ho proprio
idea di che cosa abbia fatto
precisamente però va bene ok ragazzoni
indietro perché probabilmente ho
sbloccato qualche porta non so con la
leva servirà qualcosa sarà servita
qualcosa e la scatola prima c'era sì non
era quella gara caduta perché sopra
c'era un ponte
va bene sinistra a destra non mi ricordo
più non mi ricordo più sinistra ok c'è
uno senza una gamba
ok qui è caduta la scatola è quindi
possono andato al a perfetto sia aperta
sia per tassa cosa qui che ne prima non
era aperta va bene ok ok
salve a tutti i binari 9 trequarti qui
non lo so perché sparisce è un vicolo
cieco
no ma va e allora che cosa ci ha fatto
tutto sto casino per entrare qui dentro
e poi era chiusa un bello fantastico
ragazzi quindi devo tornare indietro
vero è mica ci avrò una brutta sorpresa
no perché sono tanto buoni i creatori di
questo videogame
spero non c'è niente non c'è niente
[Applauso]
ok ok ok ok ok ok no no no no no no no
no ragazzi no no vi prego no me ne vado
l'ho guardato per mezz'ora anche ma
questa era tipo alien ma mi è piaciuto
che lo guardo fissato per mezz'ora e non
mi ha fatto niente ma è meglio così
meglio così tra virgolette perché ho
continuato a cag armi addosso ragazzi
non scaricate lo sto gioco bello lascio
in descrizione ma è soltanto per i
masochisti
ok comunque lì non c'è più nessuno
spero no non mi avvicino comunque torno
indietro ragazzi non c'è più niente da
fare qui ho aperto la saracinesca cosa
mi è servito a prendermi un infarto
perfetto e non c'è più nessun ok ok
ragazzi sto tornando indietro perché
probabilmente c'erano altre vie che non
mi ricordo
ok tipo qua è andato a sinistra prova di
andare a destra find and use which the
switch di nuovo lo già l'ho già usato lo
switch non mi è piaciuto ok st parte qua
non c'era ancora andato ragazzi cosa
sono mega supposte queste se le infila
lui e allora qui non c'è niente o cos'è
è un ascensore perfetto io lo userei gli
ascensori nei videogame nei film horror
non sono sempre al massimo ma non ho
altre non ho altre chance perfetto si è
chiuso c'è anche un'apertura ragazzi non
vorrei mai che qualcuno spuntasse ok
perfetto
ma poi è sottilissimo lo spazio mi
spiegate da dove è passato c'è madonna
arriviamo dobbiamo attendere ancora
molto o perfetto
io esco esco ne vado
me ne vado ammazza che allegria suo
posto ok ok ok
ti mettono l'uscita e poi ti fanno
comparire un caso del genere ma si può
c'è malati mentali programming hendrix
schiffer ok tu sei stronzo e anche tutti
gli altri no scusate dai visto ok ho
perso non so quanti anni di vita
soltanto con questo se volete scaricarlo
se volete farvi del male in descrizione
è niente se è piaciuto video lasciate mi
piace se volete e commentatelo mettete
mi piace alla pagina facebook che
trovate qui sotto in descrizione fatemi
sapere anche cosa ne pensate alle cuffie
9 se si sente meglio peggio comunque
fatemi sapere è niente ci vediamo
prossimo video bella ragazzi